[Music]
all right now yet another olympic
athlete who clearly
doesn't seem to love the country she's
representing
fell flat in the olympics this week as
track and field particip participant
gwen berry failed to
meddle in the hammer throw now following
that flag stunt during the
olympic trials in june now thankfully
there are other
inspirational american success stories
to cover like wrestler
tamila i'm sorry tamara masastak
who won gold in tokyo she delivered a
message about the greatness
of america and how much she loves
living in this great country made me
proud what a phenomenal athlete
how gifted and how lucky are we she's
part of our american family
also tonight i want to take a moment to
discuss the conversation surrounding
mental health
the case of of olympian simone biles and
naomi osaka in the tennis world
to be honest and this may surprise you
i'm kind of shocked people have
actually been so mean and cruel in many
cases passing judgment
of both these incredible female athletes
can we just be a little more respectful
remember
they are under tremendous pressure
they're still very young
and sometimes all of us need to take a
deep breath
relax reset move forward these young
women have both sacrificed
years and years over a decade of their
life to become some of the greatest
athletes
in their respective sports no i don't
want anyone to ever quit
or step away we always want to fight
through fear adversity
but you got to remember this none of us
ever know what someone
especially any young person what they
might be going through that you don't
know about
you just don't know they're under
tremendous pressure
and i'm sorry but some people seem
pretty heartless in their comments hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else